[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 23 octobre leur du
7-8 journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de cette édition un retour au
temps des chevaliers et troubadours la
34e édition de la foire médiévale se
tenait dimanche à châteaufort rendez
vous traditionnel du mois d'octobre pour
le village de la vallée de chevreuse et
de nombreuses animations proposées un
campement moyenâgeux installés pour
l'occasion
comme chaque mardi nous vous livrons
notre coup de coeur culture et en ces
vacances de la toussaint il est tourné
vers un spectacle jeune public
le fabuleux voyage de la fée mélodie est
en représentation jusqu'au 26 octobre à
la royal factory à versailles
et puis nous irons sur les greens de
golf à la fin de ce journal pas facile
de s'y aventurer sol quand on débute
dans la discipline
une start up a lancé une application qui
donne des conseils de jeu elle a été
présentée au golf isabella l2 plaisir
invitez tout à l'heure dans ce journal
frédéric bailly co animateur du groupe
d'action de trappes de la france
insoumise mais avant de sa 22e commune
yvelinoise reconnues en état de
catastrophe naturelle deux arrêtés
viennent d'être publiés en ce sens au
journal officiel reconnaissance à
l'issue de plusieurs événements
climatiques survenus entre 2016 et 2018
est des inondations par exemple vous le
voyez sur ces images à méricourt en
février où une marée de déchets
s'étaient créés ou encore des mouvements
de terrain qui se sont produits en 2017
à montigny le bretonneux maurepas et
plaisir notamment lé personnes
concernées ont dix jours pour déclarer
auprès de leur assureur leur sinistre à
les premiers remboursements
interviendront dans un délai de deux
mois
chateaufort fêté ce dimanche là sans
simon avec la 34e édition de sa foire
médiévale un véritable campement du
moyen-âge a été installé pour l'occasion
est toute la journée farce théâtrale et
danses de cour était proposée marylène
iapichino et nicolas landry ont
participé à ce voyage dans le temps
[Musique]
pour sa traditionnelle foire de la
saint-simon la commune de château fort a
fait un saut dans le passé le temps
d'une journée le village a retrouvé ses
habits du moyen âge c'est surtout
l'occasion de permettre aux villageois
de se regrouper un jour par an autour
d'un événement qui fédère un peu le
village
nous recherchons ce qui n'est pas qu'ils
étaient utilisés à l'époque surtout pour
les danses de cour mais après tout ce
qui est dense paysanne bas c'est plutôt
la gaieté la joie de vivre la bonne
humeur la convivialité en plus des
animations un campement médiéval était
installé l'occasion de parfaire sa
culture historique sur son casque là on
va le groin qui est un petit peu en
pointe wee a et des trous il ya une
raison une raison c'est la ventilation
on essaie de tordre le cou à pas mal
d'idées préconçues véhiculée par ma part
le cinéma le spectacle et voilà et on
doit essayer de reprendre des éléments
de l'histoire c'est un voyage dans le
temps or on se retrouve au moyen-âge
entouré de chevalier de gueux de
courtisanes et il ya toujours quelque
chose à apprendre sur place tous les
troisièmes samedis du mois d'octobre ce
sont près de 10000 visiteurs qui
viennent se plonger dans le passé
médiéval de châteaufort
[Musique]
politique les élections municipales
partielles à coignières se dérouleront
les 25 novembre et 2 décembre et on l'a
appris aujourd'hui une quatrième liste
sera candidate au scrutin au coeur de
coignières se veut apolitique guidé par
je cite le bon sens la transparence et
la confiance est la tête de liste n'est
pas encore connu l'un des colistiers et
eric giraudet conseiller municipal
indépendant est depuis la démission de
l'ancien maire et l'annoncent de cette
élection trois autres listes se sont
fait connaître
conduite par et didier fischer david
pelletier et ali ben oui céline ce
dernier sera l'invité du 7-8 journal ce
mercredi l'invité de du 7-8 journal de
ce jour et frédéric bailly c'est bonsoir
bonsoir merci nous inviter merci de
votre présence alors vous êtes co
animateur du groupe d'action de la
france est soumise à trappes avec vous
on va bien sûr revenir sur l'actualité
de votre parti ces perquisitions
intervenue la semaine dernière dans les
locaux de la france insoumise également
de son conte co fondateur jean luc
mélenchon dans le cadre de deux enquêtes
préliminaires
jean luc mélenchon qui a filmé la scène
où on le voit dans un grand état de
colère de qu'il a aussi multiplié les
déclarations mettant en cause notamment
une opération politique contre lui et sa
formation des mots durs aussi à
l'encontre des journalistes de france
info qu'il a appelée je cite à pourrir
ce genre d'action ce genre de deux mots
aussi utilisé par jean luc mélenchon est
ce que ça le décrédibilise parce que ça
décrédibilise la france à sion l'action
policière l'action judiciaire ou de
l'action parce que là les artistes jean
luc mélenchon vous avez résumé quand
même rapidement enfin
bravo d'ailleurs en quelques secondes le
tout ce qui s'est déroulé la semaine
dernière faut dire qu'on s'en est pris
quand même
plein la figure faut quand même avouer
ça moi j'ai vécu rédaction j'ai vécu la
perquisition à dire est que j'étais chez
moi à ce jour là comme j'étais d'euros
de pots et je tombe là dessus dès le
réveil la vidéo de mélenchon
perquisition à son domicile
et c'est vrai que sur le coup on se dit
mais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
bizarre et au fil de la matinée on voit
tout ce qui est mis en oeuvre en fait
tout tout l'armada judiciaire et les
moyens mis en oeuvre par la police et là
on en tant que militant on se sent au se
sent un peu touchés et en tout cas on
peut comprendre derrière les la colère
ou en tout cas
[Musique]
tous les mouvements un petit peu de
l'agitation qui a eu au siège de la
france soumise pour pouvoir accéder aux
locaux etc
donc nous n'ont en tout cas on le
comprend après ce qu'on comprend aussi
c'est que ce genre d'image qui sont
relayés
en boucle par les médias c'est ça ait pu
choquer eux
donc nourrir les journaliste de france
info est peut-être un peu fort là sans
doute sans doute mais que quand il dit
pourrir en fait c'est il s'adresse à
nous les militants en disant je vous
demande d'envoyer des arguments nous on
l'a compris comme ça en tout cas alors
c'est vrai que je comprends on avait
discuté entre vous entre militants de la
france est soumise sur les bien sûr il
ya mais il ya des il ya des militants
qui effectivement se pose des questions
il va plus loin et c'est bon
mais quand on connaît nous on connaît
jean luc mélenchon depuis quelques
années on le suit on connaît sa capacité
à s'indigner avec avec tempérament et
c'est donc si vous voulez nous on n'est
pas choqué de ça ce qui nous choque
davantage c'est toute la machine
judiciaire et médiatique qui s'est mise
en oeuvre à cette occasion là pour des
faits des faits pour l'instant ne sont
pas prouvés qu'ils sont pas démontrés
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que la jusque
là justice a voulu faire une
perquisition
donc effectivement aussi qu'on était
menés par exemple au siège du modem qui
est temps d'aller y avait pas les moyens
policiers qui a eu là d'un seul coup
contre la france a soumises et on sent
bien qu'il ya nous en tout cas on a
ressenti comme un coup politique
effectivement où on a voulu pour nous
porter un coup et quelque part ça nous a
désorganisés il faut le dire ça ça crée
le trouble aussi parmi les insoumis je
sais que beaucoup d'insoumis autour de
nous dans les yvelines se sont posés des
questions est ce que quand est-ce que ça
va s'arrêter etc etc
donc c'est ce que pour calmer le jeu
quand même jean luc mélenchon a dit hier
affirmé sur les eaux sociaux qui ne
visait pas à travers ces mots toute la
presse toute la justice c'est en fait la
solution
par exemple votre média n'est pas
concerné télé 78 fait fait son travail
de reportage ce qu'on peut reprocher
justement c'est à ces journalistes qui
certains qui se disent d'investigation
pour l'instant n'ont rien ramené ce
n'est que des ou des ragots des
calomnies ou d
la ferme la france a soumises pour
l'instant ça vient uniquement de deux
dénonciations donc la justice cherche
des preuves et vous allez voir ils vont
avoir du mal à en trouver parce que nous
on sait comment on a fait campagne
pendant les présidentielles et les
législatives dans les yvelines avec le
peu de moyens qu'on avait on n'est pas
là nous pour se faire du fric sur le dos
des citoyens et ont 20 secondes là la
prochaine action pour pour les insoumis
trappe ceux des yvelines s'est scellée
municipales j'avais déjà tourné vers les
munitions on commence à se tourner vers
les municipales le 14 novembre on va
lancer des comités locaux
pour constituer des listes françaises
soumises dans dans les communes où ce
sera possible parce que ce ne sera pas
possible partout on n'est pas présent
partout malheureusement donc mais y aura
quelques communes où on pourra faire des
listes seules ou des listes avec
d'autres mouvements ou partis politiques
qui nous rappelle que ces élections
municipales sont prévues en 2020 merci à
frédéric cabaye est d'abord une liste
animateurs du groupe d'action de la
france insoumise attrape transports ce
bus relie l'arrêt des côtes à elancourt
à la gare de la verrière en passant par
maurepas la ligne 422 du réseau stibus
va être renforcée à partir du 5 novembre
l'offre augmente aux heures de pointe le
matin avec deux courses plus longues ces
départs supplémentaires se feront à
l'arrêt du bois joli à cette heure 16 et
7h43 en direction de la verrière un
nouveau dépliant horaire sera disponible
prochainement à lagence de la mobilité
ainsi que dans les points de
distribution la toute récente ryder cup
vous a peut-être donné l envie de
pratiquer le golf pas facile pourtant de
s'aventurer seuls sur le parcours pour
un amateur si les professionnels peuvent
compter sur les conseils de leur caddie
est les autres doivent faire confiance à
leur instinct en tout cas jusqu'à
présent regarder ce sujet de patrick
jacques de dixmude et wilfrid richy un
caddie virtuel pour révéler son
potentiel de golfeurs voilà ce que
promet lots birdie une application pour
mobiles présentés ici sur le parcours du
golf
isabella à plaisir le mode de
fonctionnement est simple dès la
première partie le joueur pourra
bénéficier de conseils pour optimiser
son plan de jeu pour des tarifs allant
de 499 à 100 euros par an donc là pour
le trou numéro un
on me dit de jouer le driver donc on ne
frustre pas trop hein
un fer 5 un gap wedge ensuite une
approche punch et 85 % de chances
d'atteindre mon objectif et ensuite je
n'ai plus qu'à remplir la carte en
disant driver faire singapour edge et le
nombre de postes
et simplement ça me sert ça ne change
pas la routine habituelle 20 golfeurs
qui a l'habitude d'avoir une carte de
score et un crayon dans la poche
aucun appareil de mesure n'est
nécessaire mais l'application est en
mesure de calculer la difficulté d'un
coup en fonction des aptitudes du joueur
afin de déterminer quelles sont les
probabilités statistiques que vous
atteignez telle grille nous que vous
atteignez tel fairway ou que vous
puissiez
avoir le bonheur de réussir en dehors
dit sur tel ou tel trou à l'ensemble des
téléphones devraient être prochainement
compatible et de nouvelles
fonctionnalités interdite en compétition
sont déjà en cours de développement
[Musique]
et pour clôturer ce journal mélanie
poken hoareau jean au plateau bonsoir
votre coup de coeur de la semaine
mélanie c'est un spectacle magique et
poétique et oui c'est le fabuleux voyage
de la fée mélodies dans ce spectacle a
été pensé en 2011 notamment par
stéphanie marino mélodie est donc une
fée à qui il arrive une mésaventure elle
perd une de ses notes le la à cause d'un
coup de vent
le problème c'est que cela est une autre
très importante c'est celle qui permet
notamment aux instruments de s'accorder
j'imagine que melody va essayer de
retrouver cela ne met pas tout seul
grégory la fée va faire appel au public
les enfants vont être tour à tour l'eau
le vent le soleil les plus grands les
parents et les grands parents ne sont
pas en reste ce fabuleux voyage est
truffé de références comme mary poppins
et noir désir mais pas que il ya plein
d'univers différents qui m'ont inspiré
pour l'écriture des textes il ya plein
de textes eux-mêmes qui m'ont inspiré
comme par exemple le petit prince aussi
et l'envi en fait les venues au départ
de raconter une histoire autour de la
musique pour les petits pour les initier
un peu à ce qu'est la musique avec un
univers très féerique très poétique
une question importante qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait votre coup de coeur
sa simplicité alors pas dans un sens
péjoratif bien sûr mélodies nous
entraîne dans un monde poétique et
magique poétique car on découvre tous
les éléments qui composent la terre le
ciel la mer et la terre bien sûr et
c'est aussi magique parce que stéphane
et stéphanie marino joue avec les ombres
chinoises
elle jouait si introduit par fois et
comme on n'est pas à l'abri d'un autre
coup de vent le fabuleux voyage est à
découvrir à la royale factory de
versailles jusqu'à vendredi
merci mélanie ce spectacle et bien
d'autres choses encore à retrouver dans
l'émission le 7-8 culture présentée dans
un instant dans quelques instants par
vous est le journal touche à sa fin
cette édition est à revoir sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]